how did you raise the budget for Rex
Park Curse of the Golden Buddha so we we
took that out of our savings and you
know for that
we've been saving for years and I just
had this conversation with my wife uh
really for all of our films it's like I
have to make this I just I don't know
what it is about me but I have to make
this and
I needed to get it out of my system and
I thought that
when I made Rex Park I thought that if I
make this I'm good because I made it I
gave myself a shot
but that wasn't the case
but it was the case when I made four
Amigos
when I made four Migos
I was okay with never making another
film again or not even being a part of
the industry again because that was what
I needed for my internal soul to
accomplish
um and then obviously it led to other
stuff but
I think sometimes you have a voice in
you
and you can choose to listen to it and
apply action or you can ignore it
and
I don't think I could have I would have
regretted life
if
I didn't listen to that voice that said
you've got to do it you can't you can't
give up now
um you have to do it
so I dipped into my savings
and mind you when we talk about
stability being in I.T it gave me the
ability to have a savings and and my
wife work in us working together and
aligning our efforts and savings to make
those films
it was so vital towards the maturity
of myself as a creator
because even though
some people will say it's horrible some
people will love it it's low level sex
fart jokes
it's very experimental like when
different characters come up on the
barcodes it'll be yellow for one
character and then purple for another
character or when my character gets
slapped with poop the barcodes turn
brown like it was and there's cheesy
really just bad Graphics it was very
experimental that I found hilarious
because that's just my sense of humor
um my wife absolutely hates it I have
friends that absolutely hate it and then
I have other people that absolutely love
it and I knew that that's what that film
was when I created it but by creating
that film
and getting the confidence in this in
the schooling of doing there's something
to be said about experience and doing
that
once you're able to build that
confidence and that trust in yourself
that you can do it and you're able to
see like onset
where you can get better how you can get
better how you can treat people better
how you can talk to people better how
you can collaborate better because you
can't make a film without all of your
talent and crew you just can't it you
can shoot yourself but it's a boring
film you need the collaborate
collaborative effort of everyone
um and that's the beauty of film it's
it's collaboration
but without it I would have never gotten
to the point where I'm at now which is
10 steps further than where I was three
years ago because the films the national
commercials the print jobs and I've
worked with Apple Samsung McDonald's
Subway like you name it I didn't do
anything for my career didn't push me
forward or anything it all it did was
give me knowledge
um as to what it looks like on set how
do people kind of do things I did take
that experience and then applied it to
my films
um but it
you have to get that first film out of
the way
what resources did you already have
so I had the Blackmagic pocket Cinema
Camera 6K
um so here's one of the big lessons that
I learned on Rex Park to four Amigos in
a pizza boy rig on Rex Park I had the
Sigma 18 to 35 millimeter lens because
everyone raved oh this is the lens the
sharpness it's so great
they're right it's a good lens but what
I realized in making that first film is
what my style was and what I wanted to
capture you can't capture within 18 to
35 mil
I like shooting in 50 mil to 100 Mil and
in that space
so because I I realized that that with
the Blackmagic camera now with the
Blackmagic pocket Cinema Camera six to
6K you shoot that Raw
and I paired that with the Canon L2
series lens 24 to 105 lens
it did two things it gave me the focal
range that I wanted
and it allowed me to save time on set
because a lot of times you're running
and gunning when you're shooting because
I didn't have to change out the lens I
could just zoom in zoom out zoom in zoom
out
it it changed everything for me because
I was able to get a higher quality
production just out of the the lens
camera setup because in reality yeah you
can have the three-point lighting system
right front side and the back to kind of
separate you from the background but
when you're shooting 10 scenes in three
hours in one location you don't have
time for all that so make sure that that
person that's in light that okay they're
good and you can be agile so every time
you shoot a new scene you're going to
move that light boom but if you have to
set up three lights
you might not be able to get that in
time and if you don't do it that day you
might not be able to get that location
again
so there's there's little things and
caveats that you learn
from shooting a movie and having that
black magic with that 24 to 105 mil lens
and one powerful light just one I would
tell any filmmaker we all know lighting
is is one of the most important things
when shooting
spend the money on a real powerful light
because that one powerful light would do
you more Justice than having three
lights that aren't as powerful and I
learned that on my lesson on Rex park
because we were shooting this scene on
the background right and it was really
bright it was sunny outside and one of
the things that I hate and I did it and
I hate it when I see it but it was it's
because the tools that I had at the time
is for any filmmaker out there if you
want to light it right you light for the
background
you put that
um
uh you put your aperture settings for
the background so it's not overblown and
you can see all the details then you
light artificially your actor in frame
so then that's how you get that really
good dynamic range and balance where the
background is not overblown and this
person is is
in shot lit well if you like the actor
in front and it's so bright in the back
then that means that's going to be blown
out just so you can like this person
well and that tends to not look well in
the final product
so lens
camera
one powerful light and sometimes you can
even just do like a little bounce board
to just kind of get what's bouncing off
so you already had those in your
filmmaking kit
if it will I bought those oh you bought
those so I bought the black magic pocket
Cinema Camera 6K because I knew that it
was probably the most cinematic looking
camera that you could get at the time
for that budget
um and then I bought the sigma and then
and then I bought cheap lights that's
how I knew like the eBay light kit even
though there's three of them it just it
did what it needed to do to teach me my
lesson but it wasn't good enough to
produce the result that I wanted from a
production value and quality standpoint
but I did have to bite down and buy the
camera and buy the lens ah but then you
use them going forward to other
Productions okay so that helps with the
budget going absolutely because now it's
almost like an investment
you already own that and there's there's
power especially in 2022 there's power
in owning your gear because you don't
have to wait to shoot something you can
shoot it outside in your yard your Park
your parking garage your friend's house
you can shoot because you own it so when
you buy gear in a sense you're investing
in yourself and the extension of your
capabilities
do you ever factor in when will this
gear be obsolete when will I when will I
need to move on there'll be something
bigger and better
no because you know you can still watch
a DVD that shot in 40 that that is in
480p final rendered and still enjoy it
and in reality
this is a really good advice for
filmmakers
you have to make sure that if you're
shooting in 6K 4K 12K that your computer
can handle it because if you don't have
the right GPU CPU RAM and all of that
stuff to shoot
it's it's not going to work so like with
editing four Amigos and Pizza Boy Rick I
had to buy a 30 90 TI I didn't want to
put that on my credit card but I had to
buy that GPU to edit because once you
add color grading and a lot of times I
like to sonically and Visually I like my
films to kind of look like 80s and 90s
really I like it to look 90s but
sonically sound 80s
um
that once you
convert that digital footage to film
grain you add your color grade you
soften the images so it doesn't have
that digital sharp look because it's
film
that GPU and that CPU is working and
your computer will have a hard time even
with the 3090 TI to do 6K raw a lot of
times you have to take that 6K do a
1080p timeline do while you're editing
and hope that when you render in
something like DaVinci that it doesn't
crash
so making sure that your computer is is
Beefy enough to handle that footage is a
big thing because if if not
don't let that stop you from not filming
but maybe the Blackmagic 6 is not the
best option maybe the Blackmagic 4K
is the best option because you can shoot
4K raw and maybe that doesn't tax your
systems much or maybe the original black
magic where you still get that cinematic
1080p because your system can handle
that 1080p
but it's better for you to to be
Progressive and shoot and make
advancements
than to wait and wait and wait for gear
now if you're going to upgrade from
something like the original Blackmagic
or you can get something better
then yeah save up for it plan for it but
don't let that stop you from creating